mark cuban now says that 80 of his
non-shark tank deals are in crypto
that's right the billionaire
entrepreneur who's famous for building a
number of companies during the dot-com
boom and the owner of the dallas
mavericks is going all in on crypto he
said eighty percent eight zero percent
of all the non-shark tank deals are
crypto that's crazy here is a quote that
we have from we said the investments i'm
making now are not in traditional
businesses eighty percent of the
investments that i make that are not on
shark tank are in or around crypto
currencies he then went on to talk about
his bullishness on smart contracts
especially around dows nfts d5 and more
he said what really changed everything
was smart contracts smart contracts came
along and that created defined nfts
that's what changed the game that's what
got me excited that's why it's a lot
like the internet and so ultimately what
we know is that mark has been investing
very heavily he has been all over
digital coins nfts investments in many
blockchain companies as of april of last
year he was 60 bitcoin 30 ethereum and
10 the rest now what i find very
fascinating about mark's comments is
that smart contracts it's really just
automation right it's software code that
automatically executes based on preset
parameters it basically says if john
sends me this token that represents the
deed to his home then i will send him
one bitcoin that code executes based on
those parameters as long as john sends
me that actual token that represents the
deed of his home then the one bitcoin
gets sent to there's nothing i can do to
stop it and there's nothing that john
can do to stop it ultimately it is
software code that simply executes that
is what automation is all about it's
about the efficient pursuit of
transactions it removes middlemen
removes those rent seekers so the idea
of a smart contract it's a shiny term
that nixabo coined but ultimately we are
talking about execution of automation
automation there's very few people in
the world who think that automation is
not going to eat all sorts of different
industries one of the problems with
automation before we got into all these
digital assets is that you can't
actually automate transactions if you're
still reliant on legacy technologies so
for example i always use the example of
imagine if i try to take a cd-rom and
put it into a cassette tape player it
doesn't work imagine if i wanted to send
a song via the internet to john but i
actually had to use a cd-rom it takes a
lot longer it's less efficient
ultimately that's what we're talking
about here how do you have an automated
financial service if you still are
reliant on the banks to send wires
every day
with some sort of delay it's not very
easy and so ultimately when you get to
digital assets digital stocks bonds
currencies and commodities then you can
have true automation the digital assets
unlock the automated world that
automation is driven by these smart
contracts and i personally think that
majority not all but majority of
transactions in the world will be
automated because they will leverage
these smart contracts so i think mark
cuban understands much better than most
people give them credit for this is
going to change the world it's going to
change every single industry and there
will be trillions of dollars of economic
upside that is captured and created by
the entrepreneurs and the investors who
are courageous and have high enough
conviction to go and find where this
value ends up actually living